summer is here and many of you will be
going to the beach and we got something
for you Amazon books editorial director
Sarah Gilman is here to share her top
recommendations for a great Beach read
good morning how are you doing good
morning I'm great I love summer books
this is my favorite reading season all
right well let's jump right into it so
first you have a book you say became an
unexpected favorite and it's published
by Simon Schuster which like cbs's
division of the Paramount Global family
yeah that's not why you picked it no
that's not why I picked it it's lady
Tan's circle of women by best-selling
author Lisa C and I admit I heard the
description it didn't sound like it was
for me but my colleague Aaron said you
need to read this and I did I'm so happy
I actually made this my Sarah selects
July pick I love this book so much it's
based on a true and really extraordinary
story about a real woman in 15th century
China from an elite family called tan
yongshan and the expectation is that she
would become a wife and a mother but she
descended from a long line of female
physician so her grandmother taught her
how to practice medicine so during the
the time only men were considered to be
doctors but because of cultural norms
they could only treat women from behind
screens they couldn't physically touch
them while they were treating them and
because lady tan was a woman she was
actually able to work directly with
women and she ended up saving a ton of
lives it's it's part female empowerment
it's part mystery it's just an
extraordinary book it's always
interesting when you start a book and
you think I'm not going to like it and
then you end up liking it which says to
me it must be really good it's so good
I've always loved historical fiction but
this was amazing then you have a book
set and an adult summer camp yes you
were saying is that a thing it is a
thing it is
um I you know I've looked into it I
think I'm a little old for it I think
it's your like 20s and 30s
um so it's that summer feeling Bridget
Morrissey and said an adult summer camp
and the main character goes and
reconnects with a handsome man from her
past but she ends up falling in love
with his sister instead yes so this has
all the summer camp tropes it has color
Wars it has dining Halls it has the
heightened emotional scenes at Camp
dances is and I went to summer camp for
13 years of my life it is a huge part of
my personality and I have a very high
standard for summer camp anything and
this exceeded my expectations it's just
a great book another book on your list
is a spy Thriller many twists and turns
and you call it a sunburn book oh my
gosh yes this is my new phrase I'm
coining it here copyright Sarah Galvin a
sunburn book is a book that you start
reading on the beach at a pool and
you're so immersed in that you forget to
reapply your sunscreen I've done this
where I forget to pick my kids up at
school
um I get so in I know it's horrible but
so this book is going zero okay Sarah
yeah this has been a really good it was
really good it was you like the children
they're the best so going zero Anthony
mccartan it's a techno Thriller and it's
a little bit like a mashup between the
TV shows 24 and The Amazing Race with
Michael Crichton Vibes it is about 10
contestants who compete in a competition
to see if they can beat a brand new
Cyber surveillance system by staying off
the grid for for 30 days so if they fail
and they find all 10 of them then the
company that created the technology
actually gets very lucrative government
contract okay so the tech Geniuses are
totally stumped when a mousey librarian
ends up outsmarting the system and the
how and the why are really the pivot
plan I like the sunburn book phrase I
like that now you have an unbelievable
true story you say yes so if you like
non-fiction at the beach The Wager by
David Graham he wrote killers on the
flower Moon which is being adapted movie
yes
so this book is it's the best kind of
narrative non-fiction you read it and
you cannot believe that this is true it
is about an English warship that set
sail in 1740 it crashed on a desolate
Island two years later 30 of the 250 men
wash ashore in this ramshackle boat
they're emaciated and they're called
Heroes because they survived but six
months after that three more men wash
ashore even more ramshackle boat even
more emaciated and they say the men on
the first boat were not Heroes with
their mutineers and it kicks off this
life or death trial to see who's telling
the truth I could listen to you all day
I love house you can talk books every
day I know sunburned books I know you
heard it here first or or forget I have
babies books
[Laughter]